Framy  stimulates creativity
by allowing us to create animations and characters
using a wealth of real facial expressions
By clicking just few buttons
Framy can create movie-like effects
integrating and combining photos with video clips
However, Framy is not just a tool for producing videos
it is also a platform
to express yourself and your emotions
It’s a great channel to share your custom animations
and exchange stories from your imagination
with people all over the world.
Google has a wealth of experience and tools
to help you build a successful app business
Google Play provided Framy
with a lot of useful ideas and advice.
For example, Google Play recommends adopting Material Design
with enabled Framy to generate
a new design scheme
and a simple and unified workflow.
In the creation of Framy
The developers also incorporated
Various services provided by Google
Such as Google stage rollout
Framy is an app that contained a lot of new innovative features
Through Google Staged Rollout.
Framy can introduce new features
to a limited set of users
And according to their report
to revise the problem and improve
before releasing them to the public
Staged Rollouts is especially
useful for Framy in designing new experimental features
Framy also leveraged Google Cloud Test Lab.
It enables Framy to test on multiple devices
which saves a lot of testing manpower and time.
We can then make system adjustments according to device types
therefore greatly improving user satisfaction
with our app performance
Amongst various Google features
Framy also adopted Google Translate
Which provided different language support
and minimal language barriers
on Framy’s social media platform.
This resulted in a massive boost
to our user ratings
which increased from 3.5 to 4.1
and the number is still improving.
In the future, Framy will continue to improve
and incorporate relevant Google services into its workflow
in order to make Framy
a unique, and user-friendly app that everyone can enjoy.